at this point he's flinging all over the
place i didn't have the choke like fully
in so he wasn't going to sleep
he pulls out the pistol that he had just
shot mark with
and he reaches back like this and he
puts it against my head i can't
there's nowhere to go i'm like all right
i got so much [ __ ] resources
yeah he was a shitty terrorist where he
could cycle through his guns
they sent their way i know
[Music]
another episode of hot boxing hell yeah
i'm mike tyson i'm evan britton and
today we have a few heroes with us
yes we do that's a great way to
introduce these guys man no doubt about
it man
couple of heroes we've got spencer stone
who will get into your incredible story
in a minute and we've also got our
favorite veteran of all carlos mcafee
in the house great to have you man tell
us
chaotic in vietnam what was it like
there was any any kind of control
i looked at movies and there was like no
no but who was in control
well that depended on where you were at
any one time
and whoever took control really that's
what it appears
like seemed like on television nobody
was in control until somebody stood up
and said this is how it's going to be
the people in washington thought they
were in charge and then it went down
from there
until you got down to the guys getting
shot at and
shooting back and then those are the
ones that the real heroes
they're they're the ones that did the
job and
the circumstances were different for
everybody i mean we talked
you say you got a couple of heroes here
all
those people are heroes that faced up to
what they had to face
but how did you receive missions you
know in such a chaotic state like
vietnam how do you um how did you get
the missions
did people send missions to you that we
had to take over this bridge that we had
to
infiltrate this um facility yeah as it
structures down mike
that's exactly right i mean you've got
an overall objective for a unit
or a large army for that matter
and something has to be done and you
break it down into pieces
and so it gets down to where you got a
lieutenant a captain a sergeant somebody
in charge of
other people and equipment that got to
go
kill those people that are trying to
kill you
it really gets fundamental and i hadn't
thought about before
but almost like a boxing match or
something when it gets down
into the core uh and those are the guys
how do you know where to find the enemy
at uh
they let you know when you get around
them because they're starting to try to
shoot at you but you don't know this
town is the enemy's town you don't know
that uh
not really usually we we would think we
were blindfolded
it's going in blind huh initially i was
an advisor with the vietnamese marines
and so
i was advising the vietnamese the
southern vietnamese
against the enemy and they usually kind
of knew
where they had to go and what they had
to do and then we were there as advisors
to
make sure that they had the wherewithal
to do the mission
whatever they were trying to do how do
you prepare for that how do you train to
be in the jungle that you
you're not familiar with you never had
any kind of inclination how do you
prepare for that that's an interesting
interesting question mike i've i thought
about that a lot because
you look back at the recent wars
you prepare you learn the core
the core traits you learn your job
and then they just put you with that job
into a
terrain into a a war
if you will korea vietnam
the mideast where they are you don't
learn that area you don't have time you
go
in with your with your traits you get a
job
you figure it out and you go do it
people that have not experienced that
would have a lot of trouble
understanding it because
they talk about all the planning for war
and combat
and once once you launch and once those
shots start firing you just you
got to throw the plans away because then
you're dealing with your gut training
and that's why certain units stand out
in other units and don't stand out
because they didn't get the training
in the discipline through that
whoa well can i just say i feel like a
[ __ ] would you guys
um introduce yourselves with your
rank your ranking i i'm a retired marine
uh a retired lieutenant colonel i was an
artilleryman
and i retired a lot of years ago i
retired in 1975.
wow not long after vietnam
well about i i was in vietnam twice
i was an advisor once and i was a
battalion commander
at the end of vietnam i had an artillery
battalion that i brought out of da nang
at the end of the war and are there
friends there many never forget
there are a lot of friends that you
never forget and actually
at my age not many of them are around
anymore but
um no the when i was an advisor the
attrition rate was extremely high
later the attrition rate out of when i
was there
at the end uh was not so high it was
pretty quiet
have you ever seen the flamethrowers
those guns before
yeah i have happily i've always been on
the right end of them
yeah there's some news before come well
yeah
yeah at that time we were using them
quite a bit
that had been such an inhumane i always
weapon i feel like the the vietnam war
was probably the hardest war
for any of us to fight no one
what do you what would your perspective
on that be uh i
i it's interesting you asked that
question because wars are so different i
have a grand nephew
that spent seven or eight tours in
in the current wars and he and i have
compared notes
and it was enlightening to both of us
when we
compared what happened when and where
how the war was fought from an
individual standpoint
not from a big strategic standpoint
but how the individual
faced the situation and as you say
spencer the
vietnam was very very very difficult
but it what you guys
what the people are facing today and
have been facing in the last 20 years
in the east are just it's totally
different
and totally different lethality
different weapons
and the vietnam was different because of
the the
the uh canopy you really couldn't see
in the grass i mean you were terrain you
were blind
almost much of the time uh yeah so
i did about four years in some change in
the air force
uh i was a medic and
originally i went in to go do pear
rescue but i wasn't wasn't able to get
into the program
ended up failing out of another school
and then just being reclassed as a medic
which
really just in the end is what i want to
do anyway medical field has always
interest me and things like that so
i kind of fell into where i needed to be
i started working in a pediatric clinic
at first
uh so just working with kids and stuff
like that uh
and that was awesome loved that did that
for a few years and then i got stationed
on this
little island in the azores which is
right off like 700 miles off the coast
of portugal
uh and i did ambulance services out
there that
like that place man it was supposed to
be a short tour
you know but uh it was more of a party
on that island because we only
we only had like 500 air force guys it's
more of like a gas station
you know so everyone's pretty healthy
there's not really much going on
and and then you know pretty much
about three years into my contract with
the air force the terrorist attack
happened
and then i essentially became the poster
boy for the air force
for the rest of my career i traveled
all over the place for them doing
speeches doing really anything they
wanted me to do
when i went to the white house a few
times uh so that was a really cool
experience
wow what about the white house i know
people have been there before i met the
people i've never met a president before
you know he left some other country
never met an american president it was
crazy i mean just like everything that
we were me and my friends were
experiencing at that time
was like we almost became like so numb
to it that like we were just it was like
we were living in a dream
because it was just like one amazing
thing after another like the day we met
the president
we had our medal ceremony in the
pentagon courtyard
and the entire pentagon came out and our
you know our families are there that was
the best part about it uh is that
you know we got to bring our families
along with us and
like i had a moment when we were flying
to dc that i realized
that it was the first time my mom
brother and sister and i had all even
been on an airplane together
and so and then we're going to the white
house you know so it's just
a crazy crazy experience and we go
and you know i get a purple heart the
airman's medal from the secretary of
defense
ash carter my my friend anthony who's
not even in the military gets a medal of
valor
from the secretary of defense my buddy
alec gets the soldiers medal
um and then you know we go pretty much
directly
from the pentagon to the white house and
we're getting ready to go into the oval
office
and it was like it was just so surreal
because i go in president obama at the
time
and uh he's just looking down at like
some briefing or something like that i'm
the first one to walk in
and he just looks up and he goes hey
spencer how you doing man and i was like
oh [ __ ] like i didn't know what to do
like i'm in my uniform i don't know i
was supposed to salute you
or or what but i just went up and said
how you doing shook his hand
and uh we like had a private 15-minute
meeting
with him in the office and he was just a
super cool guy
i just remember because i was sitting in
the vice president's chair
and he was to my left and i'm just like
you know kind of looking at him talking
and i'm just like you know my mind's
just blown at that point i don't even
know what to say if he said something to
me really
and i just see that there's like a red
button next to him and i'm just like
what's that [ __ ] red button for man
but they always talk about ready star
wars baby
red button
but uh yeah it was crazy uh
just an amazing experience just to be at
the white house there's so much history
there
so so i know you've probably done it a
million times but can you take us
through the train
attack definitely man uh basically
you know the back story is right i was
in the air force at the time
uh and since i
never before i joined the air force i
had never even left california
so i had never done much traveling
before and that was kind of like
you know my purpose i guess of joining
like i wanted to go to war i guess
when i was first joining what i wanted
to travel as well
i needed money for college and things
like that being so
close like being in europe but not
really in mainland europe i was like i
have to take advantage of being here
because i don't know if i'll ever
be able to do this again you know uh
only like a 300
flight to get to mainland and i had
about like 60 days of vacation saved up
so i was like [ __ ] i'm gonna go
uh with or without anybody but then i
started calling my friends up
my friend alec who was just getting off
a deployment with the army in
afghanistan
so i knew he's going to have some time
off and i wanted to see if he wanted to
meet up
then i hit up my friend anthony who was
at sacramento
state at the time in his senior year and
i was just like trying to come you know
and we've all collectively known each
other since we were 12 years old so
we're just lifelong friends
that's awesome yeah and uh i'm just
telling them hey man you don't go on
this europe trip you should come with me
uh and he was like man i don't have any
money and i was like man
just take out a credit card it's all
good baby okay
let's just go whoa
hell yeah bro wow
he applied the day i told him to do it
and uh he got approved for a ten
thousand dollar credit card so
it was just like boom we on the way baby
uh and so me and anthony started the
trip
and we started in venice my buddy alec
wanted to go meet this girl in germany
he'd been talking to for a while so
we're like alright go do your thing
we'll meet up with you eventually
uh so we went to venice uh rome
munich berlin uh and then we all three
met in amsterdam
that's a fun place too yeah amsterdam is
time you bet
yeah yeah you better i was in the
military at the time
i was just like because you're getting
drug tested yeah
definitely oh man when you get back from
vacation it's like right now right
immediately they know what's up how do
you clean that how many times
i mean you could work it in your favor
but i'm i'm the type of guy i don't like
to take chances like that yeah
you know what i'm saying so i just
figured i'll wait
it's sketchy you know it's like i gave i
gave an oath and i'm gonna
i'm gonna i'm gonna live up to it so uh
i didn't do anything uh but we still had
a great time
and uh we're like you know three days in
at this point and we're like
debating whether we should stay or not
because our next amsterdam in amsterdam
because we loved it so much so much fun
beautiful weather beautiful people there
they're all very nice
yeah because that's what people think of
amsterdam right smoke
legal weed uh the red light district
things like that but when you go to the
city it's a cool city
you know like you could spend some time
there i've heard great things you guys
are you've never been sound awesome oh
you better go i gotta go
damn you don't want to leave evan yeah
he's stuck in the fall i'm not sure
you're ready
[Laughter]
i go there i get stuck maybe
yeah i stay longer than i should my
mysterious to dry is to stop by and pick
up
smoke and come back to america i want to
stay in it for a week
and that's my flight and everything
we were close to doing that we almost
missed our train uh
like the train we trained we were
supposed to be on we almost rescheduled
ourselves to like leave two days later
but me
and my friend anthony had already bought
our tickets and my friend alec hadn't
yet so we were just like all right man
we already have our tickets like
let's just keep on schedule and get
going you know like
we don't want to go through all that and
uh so he bought his ticket
uh we're we're leaving you know it's
it's august 21st
2015. we get it's like just a regular
day
uh you know we got some burger king
and uh then we got to the train station
we're waiting to get on
and uh like initially we had bought like
the because
you know when you travel around europe
through the train system you can buy
like a trained package
right like where you can go to like 10
different cities for like a lower cost
than what you would normally pay
and uh so but we bought like the first
class version of it
and so we initially helped like this
older couple get into the
into the train and so that displaced us
the first class was like way on the
other side
and depending on what train you were on
the first class
could be like really nice or it could
just be like whatever
you know so we were just like we saw
this area and we were like let's just
chill here
so we're just hanging out for like 20 30
minutes uh
and then the wi-fi was bad uh so you
know i just told my friends hey i'm
going to go check first class see if
they have better wi-fi
and i'll see what's up over there and
i'll be back so i go i check it out
it's dope they got better wi-fi i come
back i'm like hey let's go
to first class we pick our stuff say
goodbye to the people
uh we sit down you know it's immediately
we get
like little sandwich wraps some french
wine it's it's super nice just like oh
we're headed to paris you know
like this is crazy yeah and
as we went through brussels uh the
terrorists came on board
his name was ayub al-khazani uh he was
like
later later confirmed uh isis terrorist
um and he comes on the train he's got an
ak-47
five three 300 rounds of ammunition
a nine mil pistol a box cutter
oh this is gonna be interesting yeah
yeah
it's a movie it's a movie baby
yeah well that dude like i go around
speaking all the time like this is
like what i do to pay the bills i love
it bro
keep it rolling this is amazing
absolutely
so there he right so the way the trains
are set up there's a train car
and then there's a corridor where it's
like a bathroom and you can put your
luggage and stuff in between each
carriage
and so he is in the corridor right
outside the door
that we're sitting outside of and he
goes into the bathroom
uh he's watching like extremist videos
on his phone he's watching like
beheadings shootings
he's getting pumped up yeah he's getting
ready to do his thing and so
have you seen him get on i was asleep
when we got to first class i you know
had some wine i was chilling i put my
headphones on i had like bows
noise-canceling headphones i'm listening
to like some
r b anthony hamilton you know so i'm
just chillaxing
let's go where the french girl's at you
know so uh
we're going and uh i'm asleep he's in
the
he's in the bathroom getting pumped up
and then there's two guys
outside the bathroom waiting to go one
guy is named by the
his name is mark mugalli and who i
credit him with saving my life and
really just taking the bullet for me
uh and then there's another guy who his
alias is damien he's a french banker he
just
doesn't want to be involved because he
lives in paris and things like that
and so they're waiting to go and they're
you know the guy's been in there 15 20
minutes and they're like hey what's
what's going on i don't know they're
talking to each other
basically then the door just suddenly
opens and
out comes ayub and he's got he's
shirtless he's got the backpack strapped
to the front of him so he can grab all
the magazines
and he's got the ak like this and so
that guy damien
the french banker grabs him by his
throat and just like he doesn't know
what to do it's just like initial
reaction
and starts trying to choke him crazy
crazy so it becomes like a whole big
scuffle in that area but like no one
knows what's going on because it's
closed off
right it's like a small little space and
uh mark
uh who's a badass he uh ripped the ak
out of his hands and he's an american
citizen but he moved to france when he
was 18 and he's been living there ever
since
uh really cool guy and uh he rips the ak
out of his hands
runs into our car with it uh because
he's like all right i'm just gonna get
it away from him you know create some
distance
uh then the terrorist i guess was able
to knock out uh
damien the banker and uh what i believe
happens
because the only thing that makes sense
to me uh is that he pulled the pistol
out and then as he pulled the pistol out
he he fumbled the magazine out of it
and so he only had one bullet left yeah
and you know when the magazine's out
and you and you shoot like it's not it's
not going to stick back and let you know
it's empty and so he marks running
he picks up the pistol he shoots him
through the glass
the bullet goes in his upper left back
shoulder bounces around his rib cage
broke breaks two ribs collapsed his left
lung
and then comes up and out of his neck
and severs his carotid artery so he's
so do you feel that bullet moving inside
of you when it's flicking shame
i talked to mark and he he said no like
he just said
it it felt like like just a big like
boom hit his back and he just fell down
wow and then
he saw he just said he you know saw the
blood going over his eye and everything
he he said it was warm like coming out
of his neck and everything and
so he just plays he crawls underneath
the seat and he said oh i was just going
to play dead
and uh he just kind of assumed that the
terrorist was coming up to
you know just finish him off put a
bullet in the back of his head and so
uh that happens and like
like you said i'm still asleep but there
was a yeah he no he doesn't pass out
he's awake the entire time oh wow
uh i guess he like looked at his wife
under the underneath the seat uh while
that was happening too it was like
making eye contact with her
yeah but there was a train employee who
saw what was going on
and he took off in the other direction
towards the front of the train so
we're i'm say i'm facing the front of
the train right now i'm on the aisle
seat and my buddy is on a single seat
across from me so there's like you know
it's just airplane aisle size
he takes off right past me that
commotion like wakes me up and i'm like
why is he running like that you know
like that doesn't seem normal
yeah and so i take my headphones off
i turn around and uh well i hear
as soon as i take my headphones off i
hear glass breaking people screaming
i turn around the first thing i see is
the terrorists picking up the ak-47 off
the ground and then just
loading around into it he hadn't he
hadn't yet
that was the thing uh so he it looked
like he either like short stroked it or
jammed it or was on safety or something
like that
and he just hadn't started shooting yet
and i'm just like looking like i'm
turning around looking down i'm at the
aisle
and i'm like like like what's going on
like there's like i felt like there was
something wrong with his gun
and then my buddy hits me on the
shoulder and he says go spencer and i
was like oh [ __ ]
like i gotta go you know like i'm in the
isle seat like you have
you gotta get up first and uh so i just
pretty much
i figured you know you're going 200
miles an hour on this train
there's nowhere to go he's got a loaded
automatic ak-47
you know you're either going to do
something or you're going to wait there
and just
wait to get executed and
so i was just like might as well just go
out in a blaze of glory and i ran at him
and as i'm running at him there was
nothing wrong with this gun
uh i guess and he he points it at me
because i'm you know
the only dude standing up big white guy
running at him
he pulls the trigger doesn't go off uh
it was actually a bad primer uh and if
anyone is listening to the podcast
it doesn't know what a primer is it's
what ignites the gunpowder
in the bullet casing and actually makes
the bullet like propel at you and
shoot you uh so that was a dud click
doesn't go off that gives me enough time
to get to him
i tackled him uh he hit me in the face
with the gun as i tackled him so
i couldn't even see anything on my left
eye it's all busted up already
and we're kind of like you know on the
ground and i'm
but luckily i've been practicing jiu
jitsu uh like one year prior to that
and uh so like that's immediately what i
went to i was like
if i could just get up in this dude's
face i know i can do something because
like you know i'm familiar with firearms
and things like that it's like if you're
up in close and
if you're right here there's not much
you can do you know you can like
steer the gun away from you if you need
to and things like that so
uh we're on the ground wrestling i'm
trying to grab the gun from him but i
can't see anything i just got
like i'm pretty dazed at this point and
i just feel him like rip the gun out of
my hands and i was like oh [ __ ] like i
just kind of expect to get shot in the
head or something
and so i stand up really quick and then
luckily he
i guess he didn't have the gun in his
hands i uh take his back
and i put him in a rear naked choke and
then i flung
myself and him against the train in
between this table and a few chairs
i like smack my head against the glass
bust the back of my head open
uh and then you know at this point
he's flinging all over the place i
didn't have the choke like fully in so
he wasn't going to sleep
and uh he pulls out the pistol that he
had just shot mark with
and he reaches back like this and he
puts it against my head
and there's i'm you know there's chairs
tables to the right of me
i can't there's nowhere to go i'm like
all right i got so much [ __ ]
resources
yeah he was a shitty terrorist but he
could cycle through
so he pulls out the pistol puts to my
head click doesn't go off i'm like oh my
god and
it's like you know how can you explain
any of that other than it was god
in my opinion you should just go to god
now
i'm making a point of everything i i do
i try and
you know give god the credit because i'm
just like there's no way
that i would be here if it wasn't wasn't
for him so
my buddy simultaneously pretty much as
he pulls the trigger runs up
grabs the handgun out of his hands pries
it out uh and then he starts to
hit him in the face with it you know
just with the with the end of the pistol
and uh i'm thinking he doesn't have any
more weapons
and i just hear this like well i just
feel this burn
on the back of my neck and i'm like oh
and then i look over at my thumb
and then my thumb's hanging like halfway
oh yeah
and but i'm confused at this point
because i
i didn't see the knife and uh
i just go oh how did that happen like i
literally said get my head
and i look over his shoulder because
right i'm on his back
and i just see him with this like
extended like six inch box cutter blade
and he's just going like this i mean
he's going and cutting up my arm
and everything and uh i just screamed
like
he's got a knife he's got a knife get
him off me i push him off me
and at this point me and my friends are
all pretty much surrounding him but it
was like the first moment too
that like no one had a weapon in their
hands and so we just like all looked at
each other for a second we were like
oh [ __ ] like just start punching him
kicking him do whatever we could
and then he either like flung himself
into me
or he was pushed into me or whatever and
then i pretty much just used his
momentum and we threw him over this
table
and so now me my friend alec and anthony
are all putting our weight on the back
of his neck
like holding them down telling him to
stop moving and he's flinging his arms
everywhere
and my my buddy alec grabs the pistol
again
and cocked it back and tells him hey
stop resisting stop resisting stop
moving
he does you know he's not he doesn't
stop boom pulls the trigger doesn't go
off
[ __ ] it back again pulls the trigger so
we tried to shoot him twice with his own
handgun but that's when we've
learned that it was empty so we tossed
it and then i pretty much just said okay
screw it and then i threw him in another
rear naked choke did the same exact
thing slam myself against the train
again
and then just was finally able to choke
him unconscious uh
but you know and then once he's on i
mean i was going to kill this guy i was
seeing red
you know like and i would have felt no
remorse about it uh
and because he had honestly he he was
like you're thinking
i should die well i'm the one to think
that who might have said that
i have i have those thoughts too uh for
sure
i mean you should have seen me in the
moment i was just not
you couldn't you wouldn't recognize me i
feel like i'm a pretty nice guy but
i want to kill him for sure uh i mean
that would be
the only thing you could think of how to
shut
shut him down where the [ __ ] this guy
come from he's actually uh
from morocco yeah yeah northern africa
uh and he immigrated into spain and then
uh
became involved with extremism and
things like that
uh but so at this point right he's
he's unconscious and i'm
like i'm gonna kill him and because i
had been choking him at least for a full
minute after i felt his body go limp i
like got to a point where i had to stop
and rest
and then like reapply the choke again
but then we
my friends yell out hey this guy's been
hit and i look over the
the train seats and i see mark stand up
who had been bleeding out this entire
time
and uh like i said i was a medic in the
air force
and so i said okay hold this guy down
i'm a medic like you know make sure he
doesn't wake up tie him up do what you
got to do my friends and everyone
and a guy from the uk ended up hog tying
him with like some
employees ties and things and i crawled
over to mark
and i took my shirt off because i was
gonna like use it as a bandage to hold
pressure with
and but once i realized uh that it was
like pressure behind his wound i was
like oh that's his artery
i have to like you know grab the artery
pretty much
and so with the same hand where my thumb
is hanging off i stuck my hand
in his neck and because he you know had
a pretty good sized hole
and i could feel the artery kind of like
pulsating wiggling around
and i just put pressure on it and then
the blood flow just completely stopped
did he live he did [ __ ] and he played
himself in the movie too
good yeah i i didn't think he was going
to live though because
twitch blood huh too much i mean he had
been bleeding out the entire time we
were fighting
you know from a major artery when i came
up to him he was in a pool of his own
blood
and so even though i stopped the
bleeding i was like we are nowhere near
an ambulance or a hospital like we we
still have some ways to go
well the train actually stopped someone
hit the emergency so we had to get the
train going again too
because it's kind of i like to rag on
the employees a little bit
the employees that took off ended up
locking themselves in a safe room
when the train stopped they jumped off
the train ran across a field hopped a
fence and caught a cab and left
oh what the [ __ ] guys yeah yeah yeah so
they got some [ __ ] for that but uh so
then you had to drive the train too well
we just told the conductor
luckily the conductor stayed like the
guy driving the train and
uh he he got the train going again and
we held that position for 30 minutes uh
with my hand in his neck and he ended up
surviving
and i even at one point asked him if he
wanted to say a prayer
because i was like dude i don't think
you're gonna make it and
he was like you know i was like hey man
you want to say a prayer real quick and
he was like
nah i think i'm good
yeah holy [ __ ]
[Music]
but it's just like you said uh you know
you're
when you get that training it does kick
in because you know like i said i've
been working in a pediatric clinic
and maybe yeah i worked in an ambulance
but i didn't really have to do anything
serious
and you know i'd never seen a trauma
like that before and it was weird that
when i walked up to him
i was so calm for some reason and i was
like i knew exactly what to do
so like that's when i talked to military
and things like that
a lot of times the training is so
repetitive in the military it becomes
very redundant
and you really have to take it serious
because when something does happen and
it's gonna happen when you least expect
it
uh your training is what you're gonna
rely on and it kicks in
for sure so that goes back to what mike
said earlier
you know how do you know plan to do this
and
back to just what you said the core
training
the people know what how to do the core
needs
whatever situation comes up your body
takes care of it you automatically
react yeah you just it's kind of like an
autopilot you know
that what a what a story thanks man
to sit next to me incredible that's
that's just the first part of the story
so yeah